pegi 18 du corps à la fin du 19e siècle
les états unis en plein essor sont en
voie de devenir le pays le plus puissant
du monde
de nouveaux immigrants arrivent deux
simples avant poste devienne débile et
la civilisation gagne chaque jour un peu
plus de terrain sur l'ouest sauvage avec
red dead redemption de rockstar games
n'espère pas simplement créer un monde
ouvert mais surtout un univers plus
profond plus interactif et plus
détaillés que jamais en associant action
narration et gameplay d'une façon
inédite tandis que vous vivez
chevauchées et combattez pour survivre
en tant que hors la loi au sein d'une
bande célèbres ou non à m
[Musique]
ce jeu cherche à retranscrire le moment
clé où l'époque des hors la loi france
fin pour laisser place aux temps
modernes
il y a tout un monde à explorer qu'il
s'agisse des terres du coeur de
l'amérique ou de l'ouest sauvage
parcours et des sentiers de montagne
escarpée où des forêts denses des zones
marécageuses ou désertiques des villages
d'éleveurs ou des villes modernes et
bien plus encore tous ces lieux sont
peuplés par un ensemble de personnages
variés qui vivent au tournant du siècle
marcheurs
vous incarnez arthur morgan un homme de
main de confiance au sein de la bande
devant berline un groupe de hors la loi
et de marginaux qui cherche à s'éloigner
de la pression de la vie civilisée
[Musique]
chaque fois qu'ils sont forcés de fuir à
travers le pays
ils établissent des camps qui leur
servent de base c'est là que les membres
de la bande mangent dorment font leurs
corvées jouent à des jeux et partage
dans histoire arthur considère la bande
comme sa propre famille et il vous sera
possible d'en savoir plus sur chacun de
ses membres au cours du jeu participez
au ravitaillement du camp maintiendra le
niveau de morale de la bande en passant
du temps avec les autres membres vous
découvrirez de nouveaux secrets des
activités amusantes et pourrait
commettre des méfaits que ce soit à
l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur du camp le
monde est vivant et réagit en fonction
du joueur
[Musique]
vos armes ne sont pas le seul moyen
d'interagir avec l'environnement
interpellé un cavalier qui passe un jour
chercher des noises à la brute du
village baratiner le shérif du coin ou
intimidé un témoin pour qu'il ne vous
dénonce pas et bien plus lors d'une
confrontation vous pourrez calmer le jeu
offert empirer les choses
vous pourrez choisir vos ennemis ou
encore aux ennemis vos actes ont des
conséquences et c'est donc à vous de
décider du sens de l'honneur d'arthur
shirt youtube facebook les phases de tir
et d'affrontements ont été
fondamentalement améliorée afin de
rendre les combats plus profond et plus
captivant à chaque instant chaque arme
possède ses propres caractéristiques
avec notamment un système de
rechargement et de recul qui pousse le
joueur à rester concentrés et impliqué
dans l'action lors des fusillades
de même le lien qui vous unit à votre
cheval est primordiale et dépend de la
manière dont vous traitez votre compagne
rockster or certaines races ont des
prédispositions pour certaines tâches
[Musique]
utilisez votre selle et vos sacoches
pour transporter des armes en plus des
objets des carcasses d'animaux que vous
ramassez lors de vos explorations et de
rochas
votre lien avec votre cheval à se
renforcer au fil du temps et il
deviendra ainsi plus facile à contrôler
lors des situations délicates
le monde dispose d'un écosystème riche
et varié rempli de prédateur froid et
charognards tous intelligents et parfois
mortels voir comment la chasse permet
d'aider le camp ou de gagner de l'argent
il est possible de traquer un animal
après l'avoir blessé les peaux d'animaux
et autres objets que vous trouvez
peuvent être vendus pour récupérer de
l'argent à dépenser dans les magasins
armurerie saloon entre autres de six
cordes jean coutu c'est un monde riche
et détaillé qui vous est offert conçu
pour être explorées à pied ou à cheval
tandis que vous vivez l'histoire d'une
bande de hors la loi en fuite à travers
l'amérique
[Musique]
lors de la prochaine vidéo de gameplay
nous nous intéresserons aux missions
activités bandes ennemies en brie
âge et à bien d'autres choses encore y
compris l'amélioration de la visée grâce
au système de sang froid
[Musique]